hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
bruh Beck I'm fornicating today we're
gonna be going over the new Kia and
James um gameplay provided by fighting
cowboy link in the description history
man he's actually a very wonderful
youtuber and like I said he has early
gameplay of the two new characters so
we're gonna be diving into his video
seeing what he's mentioning and
basically going over some of the things
that these two characters have in their
moveset and stuff like that since we
haven't really seen any gameplay of
these two characters yeah like I said
credit to fighting cowboy in the
description down below I'll leave a link
to both of his videos and his channel if
you guys do want to check him out like I
said he's a pretty damn good youtuber
but first off the time stamps will be in
the description if you want to use this
or if you want to play the specific
character I'm gonna be doing nuke sure
first and then following up lastly with
Jang Joon
but renew ship remembers that the
gameplay is in arcade mode so the damage
numbers are going to be off but she
seems to be having this unique trap
ability and some moves will have this
icon and traps that will work when the
opponent is performing a block
superior block deflect or parry and then
the trap can also come from a heavy or a
zone as shown by the move list she also
seems to have normal - lights deflect
moves and some normal chains as well
that being an infinite chain that going
from heavy to light to heavy to light
back and forth and stuff like that on
the left side it says the chairs a heavy
finish for manipulation
meaning whenever that poor path meaning
whenever the heavy finisher is performed
and moves the opponent in a certain
direction I believe it said if you do it
from the right they go to the left and
if you go from the left they do it from
the right and if you do it straight from
the top they'll go backwards I believe
that's what it said I could be wrong
though and these don't attack is going
to be R plate is can be replaced in her
infinite combo chain to end it and it
can be hard fainted or saw fainted so
you can do whatever you please and she
also seems to have some decent damage as
well as she's the assassin here's some
gameplay of what the trap looks like
when you do is zone which is pretty
awesome me actually tripped them and
then double stab them with both of your
weapons for some crazy-ass damage it
seems like the trap is going to be very
hard to land but with some practice she
seems like she's going to be very strong
with that trap power like I said let me
know your thoughts about this character
and the comments below there wasn't too
much that was shown of nutri obviously
he did show off the trap ability and a
few things other than what just like
that but if you want to see some actual
gameplay and not just like cut in places
where I showed the more specific
gameplay like I say you can check his
links and the
it's both you want to see the full nine
minutes of gameplay he posted but going
over next is James Outen he has this
post called Sifu stance which
regenerates his stamina faster in this
mode and can be performed for an auto
stamina and this is performed by
pressing down on the guard brake button
which is either full block or hidden
stains depending on the character that
you play of course now maybe that being
Nobu Shere Khan could stuff like that
what's going to be very similar to that
where I have to do is hold down the
guard stance button
he has a symbol light and heavy chains
heavy light heavy heavy stuff like that
but it only seems to be two attacks per
chain so not really many options with
the three hits it's going to be like but
for specific things all heavy finishers
are going to be unblockable for him so
you can cancel heavy attacks with your
full block button or chained them into
Sifu pose to offer some mix ups and
faints which is really interesting and
you can do the same with the light
attacks as well he also has this
extended dodge move and the mighty
attacks which can be canceled in many
different ways and it's a good way to
start your combo if you don't want to do
a light attack so what this will be is
you do the mighty attack or whether
whatever them move happens to be so if
your combo is heavy heavy do the muddy
Zac and that will get rid of the first
heavy in that chain once again offering
even more chain combos technically if
you if you put in these mighty attack
moves lots of moves seem to be coming
from parries and he's the only heavy in
the game now with - forward and - side
our side - heavy attacks which is really
nice to know as well the gameplay are
going to be seeing is the seafoods pose
and some of the parry moves I mentioned
it seems like in combo a few zones
together which come from different
directions I believe he said that you
can do a zone on the left side and then
do type I then do a type of Sifu pose
where then it comes from the right so
now you have the same zone attack from
but from two different options and then
you can it also seems like you can
actually choke them and throw them on
the ground which probably has a lot of
stamina damage there's a lot of moves to
this kit and there's a lot of
unlockables and I can definitely say
he's going to be my main for this game
be a guy is going to be the end of the
video just a quick breakdown of what
some other what of some of the move sets
are and some of the gameplay and stuff
like that
like I said if you do want to see the
full nine minutes a game play without me
rambling and him talking about them and
actually showing off the gameplay
himself you can check his channel and
the kata in the description down below
I'll leave the link to that
yeah it's gonna be end of the boot today
guys hopefully you guys didn't enjoy it
let me know what you guys think about
this stuff I am super excited for these
characters to come out I think nutria
and Jun Jun are gonna definitely shake
up this game is both the other two
errors from the Wulin faction but I
definitely think James Jun is gonna be
really fun to play definitely gonna be
playing him when he releases I think I'm
officially picked my main but we'll see
how that goes later down the line
hey guys like I said ladies we would be
doing joy subscribe for new I cover the
informational side a form of that being
balanced changes here all updates leaks
stuff like that and if that guys so bit
of a great yesterday dick Forks in the
video peace out
[Music]